the NYPD expects President Trump to be
greeted by thousands of protesters today
when he returns to New York for the
first time since his inauguration Mayor
Bill de Blasio says the city is ready
mr. Trump will make a speech aboard a
decommissioned aircraft carrier
Jericka Duncan is at the USS Intrepid
with details of the president's
homecoming
Jericka good morning good morning
president Trump will meet with
Australian Prime Minister Malcolm
Turnbull right here on this intrepid
well there's a little bit of a problem
this truck is blocking us but they're
going to meet this afternoon it'll be
the first face-to-face conversation that
the two have had since the heated phone
conversation back in January and while
the intrepid provides an historic
backdrop it comes out a hefty cost for
New York City we're ready for it ray
from multiple protests were ready for
protests that move around it's something
we've become very comfortable with Mayor
Bill de Blasio says New York City is
prepared for president Trump's return I
Love New York but going back is very
expensive for the country they closed up
Fifth Avenue and they closed up 56
straight I live in Trump Tower which is
right smack great location right smack
in the middle of everything
First Lady Melania and son Barron are
still living in New York the NYPD
estimates protection at Trump Tower cost
nearly 150 thousand dollars a day when
the president visits that cost is
expected to more than double the
proposed federal budget a lot 61 million
dollars to offset security expenses for
law enforcement across the country what
we've really been concerned about is the
ongoing cost at Trump Tower does the
reimbursement to law enforcement at
least put you a little bit more at ease
what the Congress put together
substantially will reimburse us
certainly for the time between election
night and the inauguration of President
Trump and it provides some real
resources going forward for the
protection of Trump Tower and the folks
in it New York is not the only city
footing the president's bill since his
inauguration President Trump has
traveled seven times to his mar-a-lago
Resort in Florida costing Palm Beach
County roughly sixty thousand dollars a
day to provide security
people would understand that I could go
other places that I have but then they
hit me for relaxing and I don't want to
be known as a person that relaxes
because I'm working hard and I'm working
hard for the people and we're doing a
great job and this year alone President
Trump is expected to eclipse the 97
million dollars in travel costs that the
Obama administration racked up in his
entire eight years in office Charlie the
record thing